welcome dance video playing the essay
night sec night second I'd you know and
let's see some English opening and
symmetrical English yeah we got a maraca
see bite now I know my favorite opening
lines never lost with it in tournament
shares in over 20 years and won a ton of
games at least I don't remember loss
maybe I did lose a game that I
successfully have forgotten but really
not aware of any losses there each 5m
some too sometimes you can play like
that but usually disconnected with some
idea to play King h7 Bishop h6 and done
really didn't really look a lot like
that it's happening anytime soon so I do
as usual stuff put a knight on d5 and
ask ask black what is going to do about
it
that's the big problem of the black
structure against the Roxy point the
night comes 35 you usually are forced to
take it sooner or later yeah or play
stuff like that to take it sooner or
later and then you will have an awfully
sick spawn well you will have an often
sorry I'm talking a little bit strange
em you will have an offer and pawn on d6
like it happens here or you have to take
it which gives white an even bigger
space advantage something like an ED get
pressure on the e-file or ctx gives play
on the C file maybe I could have taken
on a seven but I don't I don't want to
can just keep this this great position
as is and ask black all kinds of
annoying questions what about your pawns
d 6 b 6 what about the space
non-threatening night a form which is
duly ignored
maybe you can go light xp3 maybe you
could have done that click that a bit
too quickly actually cannot take as
Bishop takes wins the exchange and if
you cannot take what is your move
hmm it's a good defense should have gone
to sea for him
I should have gone to c4 and set of c2
then I could have taken on the six now
which I cannot do in this position hmm
hmm
that's a bit annoying that I didn't do
that hmm
okay let's play normal moose it's not
stumble into some time pressure here
we should be for this I III and now i'm
getting a C pawn back it's still a huge
advantage but I think I could have gone
could have gotten gotten more nap okay
it's really is even winning other and he
has no way to save the upon check
black resigns yeah there was a disaster
out of the maroc see but it can easily
happen next position is not so easy to
play so yeah it starts with most like b6
which is not really what you want to do
it it just gets your mixer position more
yeah more inflexible yeah moves like a
six or a five later we can be 6 and so
on so I just been playing normal stuff
h5 doesn't help now we went back and I
mean he already this is this is pretty
awful to play like doesn't have any
activity e six weakens the pawn taking
on d5 I mean this is a terrible position
ready what about the c6 square and the
night is even in some danger of getting
trapped sometimes with age 3 NF form
it's pretty awful and they went here
yeah now they're already things like 97
lurking yeah if he does something some
nothing move I might be able to play
that yeah and wins material and yeah you
six just go back yeah maybe he never
sees an exchange right this kind of
stuff yeah it's as interesting Bishop
takes b6 Queen takes isn't even that
clear if you get to be three Pawn but i
have before as a good move try to just
play with this great strategic advantage
it's very difficult for him to save the
rook if he goes there
that you're not going to survive that
porn will will be the winner again after
that the end game should be should be
winning even though I made a mistake or
more than one mistakes if I was right
you have to go Roxy for that's much
that's much simpler as then these six is
really hanging for real and Bishop 83
doesn't help them something like that i
can i can just take it's a bit simpler
like this even even though this probably
wins quite easily Pepsi one you cannot
go back as this is pretty awful and
loses this back now so we got did at
that end game which is also winning yeah
the maroc see blind is something that I
really never recommend anybody to play
with black it's um it's not fun and it's
very difficult to get something active
going there are some lines not that one
but there are some lines in the barrack
see that you can maybe if you prepare it
well and that you can prepare for some
kind of stale equality if you if you do
it right but it's really not not very
entertaining to play ok thanks for
watching